there are new twists in the murder trial
of a former police officer in Dallas
amber Geiger was off-duty when she shot
both of John last September she claims
she thought the apartment was hers
yesterday a judge blocked jurors from
hearing a portion of the testimony
supporting her claim
Omar Villafranca is at the Frank Crowley
courthouse in Dallas Omar what can we
expect today well the jury's gonna hear
from more experts including the lighting
expert who's expected to talk about what
it looked like when Geiger went into
John's apartment that block testimony
came from the lead prosecutor the jury
was not present when he told the judge
he thought Geiger actions were
reasonable that's correct
a parade of witnesses including experts
and residents testified on the third day
of amber Giger's murder trial but it was
the lead investigator Texas Ranger David
Armstrong who said the layout of the
Giger's apartment complex could be
confusing there were no clear obvious
visual signs showing what lovely wrong
the former Dallas police officer is
accused of shooting both of John last
September when she allegedly mistook his
apartment for her own Armstrong
testified Geiger lived directly below
John and going to the wrong apartment
was not uncommon according to other
residents that would be 15% the jury
also heard from the medical examiner who
testified that because of the way the
bullet entered his body John would have
to have been leaning forward when he was
shot
the prosecutor suggested Jean might have
been getting off the couch the defense
says he could have been coming towards
Geiger you have no idea about where mr.
John was what he was doing that's
correct the jury also saw more of the
graphic body cam footage from the night
of the shooting John's parents were so
disturbed by the video they walked out
of the
I'm sorry I knew you didn't talk to the
victims
the only part of the lead investigators
testimony that was blocked by the judge
was his view that Geiger did not commit
a crime and that her actions were
reasonable and the reasoning behind that
was that that was his opinion trial is
expected to continue for another week
Tony so hard to watch that video Omar
thank you very much